call me dude Z will and Chad you must
discuss which astonishing Nintendo games
you think will be turned into movies
next this is game slimers begin like
excitebike what kind of movie would
excite bike be
I don't know there was no an excite bike
you were just riding that little
motorcycle around the tracks right so
it's Timothy chalamet and he's just a
he's a kid with a dirt bike you know and
then he's like and he builds a backyard
his dream is to like turn his backyard
into a dirt bike racing driver
and then it's like a little bit of a
Karate Kid thing there's a there's a
girl like dude he's new Duck Hunt it's
Larry the Cable Guy an ice cube every
year they get together and they go on
their duck hunting right Excursion and
they rent this like shitty Barn of a
place and all their buddies come out and
uh you know there's bullet holes in the
windows and they just you know eat they
just basically subsist off of uh beef
jerky and cup of farts yeah and cut and
they're just cup of farting each other
there's a good one who plays the dog